hey crazies I was thinking lately I'm an
astrophysicist and I haven't done nearly
enough astronomy videos imposter
syndrome is probably partly to blame
stop self diagnosing NIC anyway we're
gonna break this pattern right now our
last video was a nuclear fusion which
usually happens in the cores of stars so
let's talk about stars there is way too
much about stars to cram into one video
so let's focus on a specific obstacle
how do we know anything about stars that
they're so far away and lived for
millions of years by being science
ninjas ninjas yeah ninjas are cool that
doesn't have to make sense
so yes stars are very far away but they
send out light that travels the distance
for us and that light tells us a lot we
need two pieces of information the type
of light meaning its color and the
amount of light meaning its brightness
contrary to popular belief color is not
a property of matter it's a property of
light for normal things like you me or
question clone our color depends on what
light scatters off of us turn off the
lights and you don't see any color stars
are different though they make their own
light and the color of that light
depends on the Stars temperature let's
take a look at the most familiar star in
the sky the Sun it's what we call a
yellow white dwarf meaning its color is
yellowish white and its size is modest
by star standards or you might say
standards yeah that yellowish white
color is on its chromis fear meaning
color sphere which has a temperature of
about 5800 Kelvin let's be clear though
anything with the temperature above
absolute zero is making its own light so
basically everything it just isn't
always visible to human eyes whatever
particles nudge each other a little
energy gets lost as light what kind of
light that is depends on how fast the
particles are going and since particle
motion tends to be pretty random objects
with lots of particles emit lots of
different kinds of light the human body
is around 310 Kelvin so most of the
light is infrared but for a bright light
ball or the Sun there is a lot more
visible light but if it's losing energy
won't it cool down if it were an
inanimate object yes but it's not the
human body uses chemistry to replace
that energy after all humans are just
sacks of aqueous chemicals a star on the
other hand replaces any lost energy
using nuclear few
in its core the temperature in the Sun's
core is 15 million Kelvin which is like
so hot anyway if you combine a star's
brightness with its color you get what
we call an HR diagram the Sun is
yellowish white so it's right about here
on the chart but if we plot a bunch of
stars on here at the same time a pattern
develops these are the younger stars
fusing hydrogen into helium these are
the older stars fusing helium into
larger elements and these are what are
left over after small stars die
you can draw a star's entire life on
this chart so what's a year in the life
of the star basically nothing big stars
will lit for millions of years the Sun
will live for billions of years and
little red dwarfs can live for trillions
of years stars aged so slowly that we've
only seen a few actually change then how
do we know anything about their lives
because of that HR diagram we see
patterns in this diagram and combine it
with what we know about nuclear fusion
and plasmas to figure out how oldest
stars then we put the different examples
on a timeline to get a full picture oh
right that's a great analogy imagine a
group of aliens like Milton wanted to
study the human lifespan but they can
only spend a few seconds here on earth
they would show up take a bunch of
pictures and leave working really hard
to piece the pictures together later
that's exactly what we do with stars
pretty crazy huh so will you ever look
at a star the same way again let us know
in the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video we learned about
nuclear fusion come in at response time
Gaston was wondering why don't we shape
the tokamak reactor like an eight
instead of a circle wouldn't an eight
shape smash more together at the center
well maybe but a circle is easier to
make not just for the reactor itself but
also for the magnetic field the reactor
uses magnetic force to confine plasma
and plasma like any other charge
particle it just naturally travels in a
circle in a magnetic field it's already
a huge challenge that can find the
plasma in the first place we don't need
to make it any harder to zico was
wondering how dangerous hydrogen fusion
would be and the answer is it's actually
really safe sure the first time we
figured it out we turned it into a bomb
but that's what happens when you let the
military fund your project plus you can
turn most things that release energy
into a bomb so that doesn't really count
as a complaint you just have to put
safeguards in place to prevent explosion
which is something we already do with
our current sources of energy the best
part of a fusion though is it doesn't
create any dangerous exhaust it produces
helium which were in dire need of anyway
for cooling systems we actually need the
byproducts abû say it wanted to know
about quantum tunneling during fusion
okay so I purposefully avoided this in
the video my videos are already
information dense enough talking about
quantum tunneling would just have
distracted from what I was trying to say
but we'll talk about it here for a bit
hydrogen fusion begins at 13 million
Kelvin it's just that on paper if you
only consider the motion of the protons
you need hundreds of times higher
temperatures so we're clearly missing
something if we do that if we also
consider the protons as quantum
particles which is exactly what they are
then you don't actually have to break
the Coulomb barrier you just have to get
the two protons close enough so that the
uncertainties in their positions overlap
Dave long asked how cosmic rays create
things like lithium and beryllium so yes
nuclear fusion skips over a few of the
early elements on the periodic table but
fission can come back and make them
later
youjin is when you combine smaller
elements to make larger ones fission is
when you take larger elements and break
them apart to make smaller ones
interstellar space has lots of loose
particle zipping around called cosmic
rays it's a terrible name because
they're particles not raised those
articles are moving really fast and
occasionally smashed into big elements
and a little pieces that break off are
sometimes lithium and beryllium lots of
great questions this time anyway thanks
for watching see you next time